تمكنت فرق الانقاذ في ولايه هاتايا
التركيه من انتشال اثنين من افراد عائله
سوريه من تحت الانقاض وذلك بعد نحو 2009
ساعات من وقوع الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
جنوبي البلاد وفق لمصادر تركيا فان خمسه
افراد من العائله ما زالوا تحت الانقاض
ولم يعرف مصيرهم بعد
من غازي عنتاب مراسله الجزيره منتصر ابو
نبوت منتصر هل بدات غازي عنتاب تستعيد
شيئا من ملامح الحياه قبل الزلزال
نعم في الحقيقه هذا هذه
الاستعاذه للحياه بدات في غاز عنتاب نوعا
ما حركه السيارات بدات وبعض المحال
التجاريه بدات تفتح هذا كله بدا منذ يوم
امس تقريبا هذا يعني لا يعني ان المدينه
قد عادت الى الحياه بشكل كامل
ملامح الاضطراب والتوتر هو هي واضحه في
مدينه غازي عنتاب اثناء اللايف الان قبل
قليل شاهدنا طائرات هليكوبتر تقوم بنقل
المساعدات الى قرى تتبع اداريا لولايه
غازي عنتاب وهذا ما تحدث عنه السلطات
المحليه وقالت ان الجيش التركي يقوم بنقل
المساعدات والخيام الى القرى المتضرره
التابعه لولايه غازي عنتاب وهي اكثر من
500 قريه تضررت جراء هذا الزلزال وقطعت
الطرقات عنها نحن نتحدث عن تشققات في هذه
الطرقات وايضا عن تراكم من الثلوج لان
زلزال عندما وقع يعني كانت هناك عاصفه
ثلجيه والثلوج تتراكم خصوصا في المناطق
الريفيه وتبقى فتره اطول من المناطق من
المدن حيث ان الناس هنا يقومون باستخدام
سياراتهم والتحرك اكثر فلذلك يذوب هذا
الثلج اما في المناطق الريفيه فتبقى
الحركه اخف لذلك وتبقى درجات الحراره ابرد
خصوصا اذا ما كانت في مناطق مرتفعه وفي
الجبال فتبقى الثلوج فتره اطول لذلك
الطرقات مقطوعه الى هذه القرى التي تضررت
ايضا بفعل هذا الزلزال خصوصا القرى
القريبه من مدينتين والاصلاحيه كل هذا
ياتي في اطار سعي السلطات الى تامين
السكان والاهالي المتضررين سوى على الصعيد
الاغاثي او على صعيد المسكن
السلطات المحليه ولايه غازي عنتاب قالت
انها ستستخدم السكن الجامعي في غازي عنتاب
لاستضافه الاشخاص المتضررين والذين تهدمت
منازلهم في عموم الولايه هذا بالاضافه الى
الخيام التي وصل عددها الى اكثر من عشرين
الف خيمه في عموم ولايه غازي عنتاب منها
اكثر من 5000 خيمه في مدينه الاصلاحيه
تحديدا في ملعب الاصلاحيه هذا الملعب كان
ملعبا لكره القدم اليوم لانه ساحه كبيره
تحول الى مخيم كبير للاشخاص الفارين من
هذه المدينه والفارين من الزلزال الذي ضرب
ولايه غازي عنتاب ايضا هنالك عمليه مستمره
من قبل السلطات المحليه والمنظمات الاهليه
في التجهيزات اليوميه التي تقدم الاهالي
سواء على الصعيد تقديم الوجبات الساخنه
التي يصل عددها الى اكثر من 500 الف وجبه
يوميا في عموم ولايه غازي عنتاب بالاضافه
الى تقديم الاسعافات والمساعدات الطبيه من
قبل الهلال الاحمر الذي ينتشر في جميع
المناطق في ولايه غازي عنتاب من خلال
سيارته والكرفانات التي يستخدمها لاستضافه
الناس وتقديم المساعدات لهم خصوصا الاشخاص
الذين اصحاب الامراض المزمنه ايضا شاهدنا
في غازي عنتاب هنا في هذا المخيم مثلا
يوجد خيام وضعتها بلديه انت بتقديم الدعم
النفسي للاطفال وهذه كلها افضل من جهود
محاوله يعني اعاده الحياه واعاده
الطمانينه للناس في هذه الخيام شاهدنا
ايضا تمديد للكهرباء
تكثير تكثيف من عمليه التوزيع الاغطيه
والبطانيات وما الى ذلك من الامور التدفئه
لدينا درجات الحراره لا تزال بارده خصوصا
في ساعات اليوم ويوم امس سطوع الشمس كسره
قليلا من هذه البروده خلال النهار ولكن
درجات الحراره تبقى بارده والاهالي يعني
لا يزال كثير منهم خائفين كل هذا يجري
يعني في في ظل استمرار عمليه البحث وعمليه
الرفع الانقاذ في مناطق متعدده من مدينه
غازي عنتاب وايضا في مدينه نورداغ
والاضافه الى مدينه الاصلاحيه في السعي
فرق الدفاع المدني الى يعني محاوله اخراج
اشخاص اخرين من تحت الانقاذ على امل ان
يكونوا ناجين وهم على قيد الحياه
مراسله الجزيره منتصره ابو نبوت شكرا
جزيلا لك